rappelez-vous le 19 juin 2021 une
tornade frappait la Touraine et
arrachait le toit de l'église de
Saint-Nicolas-de-Bourgueil et de sa
salle des fêtes deux ans plus tard où en
sont les travaux de reconstruction vous
allez voir qu'il faut beaucoup de temps
pour refaire ce que la nature a défait
en quelques secondes confirmation dans
ce reportage de Clémence dosc
in en premier la porte d'entrée là et
donc pour moi tout un amas de gravats de
poutres d'éléments métalliques et mon
inquiétude ma première inquiétude
c'était de m'assurer que qui est
personne de sous des souvenirs aussi
intacts que les stigmates sur le
bâtiment en 2021 une tornade traversée
Saint-Nicolas-de-Bourgueil sous la
violence des bourrasques le clocher de
l'église s'est écroulé habillement
toiture et charpente au passage
on a des locataires depuis qui sont
amplifiés depuis la tornade
malheureusement ça nous fait beaucoup de
dégâts et on vient de d'intervenir
auprès d'une entreprise là un Fauconnier
et faroucheur de façon à nous faire
évacuer tous ces pigeons à l'automne
2022 les experts des assurances ont
fixés l'indemnité de réparation à 2,8
millions d'euros une somme suffisante
pour ce chantier qui prend du temps la
faute aux démarches administratives le
tableau est différent concernant la
salle des fêtes entre rénovation et mise
aux normes la commune devra débourser
1,5 millions d'euros soit son budget de
fonctionnement pas de quoi arrêter le
maire parti à la chasse au subventions
on a besoin de se retrouver nous au
niveau de la mairie on peut plus faire
de manifestations quand le 8 mai on
faisait le repas des anciens le 11
novembre on faisait le repas des
associations il y a plus de mariage mais
on a besoin de se retrouver d'un point
de vue local donc et puis on a besoin
que notre salle des fêtes retrouve cette
âme les architectes seront prochainement
désignés avant de lancer les marchés
d'entreprises la commune espère voir les
travaux débutés d'ici fin 2023